[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review
of the handmaid's tale season 4 episode
7
home this is directed by richard
shepherd and written by ya lin
chang so i first want to just delve into
all of june's story here
and then we'll go over to serena because
there's one scene they put a serena but
it's
in the beginning and then it goes back
to serena but we'll just go through
first everything with june and then come
right back to
what happens here with serena so we
directly
pick up where we left off where now june
is on canadian soil and it's now
first time we're seeing her meet mark
which is interesting to have these two
characters now
in the same scene and what i liked about
this scene was
she's got to read her reasoning now to
let them
take her and kind of you know say
everything that's
awful that's happened to her and why
she's coming to canada but what was
important was little beats like
moira saying to jun you got this because
again as we saw last episode june's
breaking through that guilt she's
feeling like she's supposed to be
running after hannah
in gilead so she's kind of pushing
through that in herself to go to canada
and not worry about hannah like that and
do the work from canada
so this is crazy because this is now
we're seeing june out of gilead
right she's in this regular life and
it's not just regular life it's this
like fancy lifestyle she's seeing
in this hotel it's a complete different
vibe
for her but what was interesting here is
there's a lot of
visual story telling on here like i
talked about what's so great about the
show but you even see a visual
motif here that is a call back to
episode three this season where
when june goes on the elevator she's
again framed in the center
the doors are closing on her it's the
exact same shot interesting
i don't know what that could mean at the
moment but it scares me a bit because
we've
learned more about mark that's not so
great this episode and he's the one
behind her with luke and
i mean can you ever really trust luke at
the end of the day so it's interesting
that they're picking that shot to
emulate there of her
standing in that elevator in the hotel i
think that's very fascinating
because last time she was in that
position she was kidnapped
why this show is masterful at directing
in cinematography again it's just in the
scene when she's in the hotel room she's
looking out the window
and she's not hearing anything mark is
saying here
right she's completely not able to even
process
all this information being thrown at her
he wants to get in this debrief
and she doesn't clearly hear anything
until
moira mentions nicole so it's perfectly
through that directing cinematography
and the sound design
showing you that june is not
carrying anything right now until she's
dealing with things that are really
important and should be important at
that moment is
reuniting with her family and so i've
always talked about the lighting right
and you'll see that in this episode too
which i'll get to about it
always showing you that gilead's always
with you wherever you go
but you see that the handmaid that june
is is always with her
because look at the production design
with the colors right and costume design
where you got the red curtains the red
kimono
red flowers red pillows and you see a
red chair here but to contrast that you
see
all these things in white as well so you
get the red and white blend of the
handmaid's outfit
so we see june gets her 17-hour rest
here
and she wakes up to luke and they have
this important conversation about hannah
what's important to note here is that
it's showing you that june's fears were
irrational like moira was telling her
that
you know luke would understand and he
wouldn't be mad at her and he's the one
who feels guilt like he's in that same
position he feels he didn't try enough
for june and for hannah but his guilt is
actually a little rational because he
really didn't do much
but what's important here to note is
that june is really
informing luke about what hannah said to
him is when they met
again in season two right when she was
younger she did recognize
june and she was saying like why didn't
you find me
and everything basically june says here
to luke but what
june leaves out here is her seeing
hannah recently which we saw in this
season
that she's older now and didn't
recognize june anymore and that
she knows that would be really hard for
luke to just process that no
she actually has now kind of forgotten
about us
and it's gonna be just to see if luke
ever finds that out and if he does how
he would react to that
and how much she could handle so what's
important here is when mark first starts
to briefing june in the hotel room
she is already starting to explain to
mark how
awful serena is right and now he's
hearing it from the victim
herself and mark obviously is
under serena's spell which will get that
payoff by the end of the episode
why this episode's so brilliant because
there's so many little payoffs that they
set up right here but
i really like how she has this
being said to mark because mark is
literally not
seeing serena for who she truly is which
a lot of fans have fallen to
spell before and characters in the past
have and how mark is
that's what makes serena such a great
villain as she has that charm about her
right
and you see what makes mark a lot more
unlikable here is how pushy he is
with getting these answers out of june
and he really is a man of his job
first and luke does the right thing here
which june loves or he's like
no we're taking a break and taking care
of the important stuff like going to see
nicole
so he brings june now to him in moira's
home
and we see emily we see nicole moira
and this really felt like an epilogue
here
and i even teared a bit when she sees
emily and
june because this reuniting scene works
perfectly because
she has nicole with her who june
gave emily to to get through the border
and june obviously helped emily get out
of gilead in general
so there's a lot of weight there and it
really is a nice
touching moment between the two of them
and what i started thinking in my head
here saying that this feels like an
epilogue now
and that we're really getting closer to
this story of june's story
is that i'm starting to think they sent
out the first eight episodes
to the critics i only watch them one by
one live with you guys so i don't know
what happens in episode eight but i do
have it
but no one's seen the last two episodes
right so i have a feeling that there's
going to be a big shocker by the end of
the season that we're actually going to
be leaving june's story and going
towards
a time jump or a mix of that with where
the testament goes
and i think that would be the best move
here because it clearly is angling that
now or we're kind of closing up
everything here and
the stories we're not we can leave
towards that time jump story but
the center focus story of june really
felt here it's rapping now because like
i had said
i like okay i was a little worried about
her getting to canada because it doesn't
let me feel like it's ending but
it is i feel and then maybe then that
works and that they should do that and
that
they could do a cool thing where they
just change the show title for season
six
to the testaments let's say instead of
the handmaid's tale instead of kind of
doing like
a spin-off word air at the same time as
hammys tell it would be cool maybe just
to kind of
break some ground and make the show just
a different title i think that would be
kind of sick
because how could you have june go back
at this point to gilead it feels silly
then right it'd feel like oh come on
they're doing this again
like no way and they leave breadcrumbs
now
for a future timeline with like what's
hannah gonna do right
what's nicole gonna be like so it's it's
kind of setting up where you could still
have june be something
from afar in that show but not the main
point anymore
so what was crazy and you kind of got to
catch quick is when june wakes up the
next day in this home
that it literally is emulating her
bedroom she had in the waterfords
again like i always say that gilead
light is coming through the window
right that gilly's always with her but
it's not just that here
it's the same exact color palette they
would use when she's in the waterford
house
and the other big thing is with the
sound is her hearing
nicole crying because that would also
happen in the waterfalls house hearing
nicole when she was crying and i swear
to god june has a moment here
because they cut to her point of view
looking around the room like checking
that
she's not back at the waterfront like it
really like spooked her out i thought
that was
really well done and what i liked here
was that when moira mentions she's
taking a call to the supermarket
june wants to go and she's like well
isn't that going to be kind of culture
shock for you
and june has this great line i've been
living in gilead all i want is culture
shock
and i think they do so well here is
you've seen in movies before too like
cast away and stuff where someone comes
back
from an island right or somewhere
stranded or a horrible environment and
they come back to normal life and it's
really hard for them to adjust
you see that with obviously vets in the
real life too and
i like that they're showing the point
that she can't just sit down and relax
like people are gonna tell you to do
like yeah june maybe she just take some
time off just chill at home
and that's the opposite of a type of
person like luke cause that's why they
show luke
his reaction and he's off center in the
frame is that
he doesn't even really understand how
could you just want to like keep going
now because
june and luke are complete opposites in
that sense where luke kind of just
stands around and really doesn't do much
and june's a doer you know she goes
she's
fearless she's brave so it's kind of
ramming that home that yeah this is what
a june character type would do
in a situation and returning back to
normal life
so it's very true to her character which
i like so when they're in this grocery
store
right after she has this little talk
with luke about the chips being
different now
there's three really important beats
here the first one
is june smiling at luke and moira here
because their problems they're having is
they didn't did they get the milk did
they get oatmeal these are good problems
to have so to her that's a relief
that's normalcy but the other important
thing is when there's a girl that runs
past
june with her mother running after her
this girl is the same age as
hannah so that is starting this
triggering effect for
june and another thing is that two women
are romantic together walking down the
aisle towards her something she would
never see in gilead so that also
is something she's processing and then
when she goes to pick out the chips
through the aisle like we'd see in loads
and fishes she
sees the eye of nina kiri aka
alma and this is because again they're
in the supermarket like loaves and
fishes and it's also this guilt of her
feeling
responsible for alma's death and then
she sees two women in red burqas
then that triggers her thinking of them
as handmaids and this will just keep
going
and she sees now the wing symbol above
the water bottles
and now she goes into a full-on like
panic attack traumatic moment
but i thought they did this all really
well and you have to show this because
this would be happening right you can't
not do this so we get this fascinating
scene where it's rita
june mortar and emily now and they're in
the house at night and it's like a
support group
right for anyone who's been through
abuse moore is talking about how
messed up they all are about sex and
they're kind of all
in a way getting it out and it's good
for them to be talking about these
things because who the hell else are
they going to talk about these things
with like these are people that were in
gilead that made it which is
i don't think many people but moira's
always got some scene stealing lines per
usual samir wiley kills it here
where when june feels like it's her
fault that moira and are having problems
she's like don't bring that aunt lydia
[ __ ] here
and june brings up this point in her
head like do you think sometimes like do
we deserve to be here
again this like survivor's guilt now
she's processing that they've been
dealing with
but maura is like being super positive
he's like we had to do what we had to
survive because especially emily you
know she ran over somebody with a car in
gilead but
again it's that realizing they were the
true victims there and they had to do
what they had to do
the ends justify the means here but when
stuff starts ramping up here and this
episode starts ramping up
is when june asks the big question what
do you guys know about serena
and this is when rita like kind of puts
her head down but she lets her know that
serena's pregnant also that it's
commander waterford so this is a big hit
to june right and
what you have to understand about june
with serena is like yeah she named the
baby nicole after serena because that
was serena
starting to do kind of like a redemption
arc and be likable
but why serena's such a tragic story and
why she's a villain in the days because
she never can just do that she can't
change you know she teases it
but she always chooses to do the evil
for her selfish needs
usually because of something to do with
a child and
that's what makes her so evil is she's
aware of it and
she doesn't care and that's why june is
completely done with serena in her mind
and
hearing that frustrates her because like
she said
to mark that was a driving force for her
to get the kids out
was as like an fu to serena but that's
why she's so angry here is because
this is the opposite this is someone she
hates getting what she dreamed of and
that's being pregnant
having a child and that of course
commander waterfords who
raped her constantly and couldn't have a
child with anyone supposedly so
it's a lot for her to process but again
i love morris switches it up here and
she's like well uh
she looked bad right guys and it's so
funny because you're trying to make june
feel better about it but like
serena didn't look bad either she looked
great in this really nice prison you
know
and june you see so mad and clear the
awkwardness more
just gets up and she's like i think we
need more alcohol i just thought that
was really good but then it kind of
leads to
the story i'm still not really caring
about where it's like moira and uno
right now and maybe this would work
in a different season for some reason
it's not really tying in well to i think
what's
going on in this season i think it's
kind of just fluff and what annoys me
about is that maura doesn't want to be
over between them and then you're like
okay maybe i like this una person and
then luna says you chose
your friend over me and my work i know
where i stand
that is what makes me not like her and
that's what annoys me because they write
these kind of stories where it's like
i love moira she's awesome and i don't
want a roof for her to be with someone
like that who's talking like that like
she doesn't even see
where she's being selfish you know and
not understanding more so i don't
understand sometimes when they write
characters that
kind of like luke too where you're like
i'm not really rooting for them to get
with them i'd rather moira tell luna to
leave at that point like screw you but
she's still running for it so i don't
know i'm just not crazy about it
is this really the person you want
someone as great as moira to kind of try
to get i i just don't get it
okay so this is where i started getting
blown away and what i mean by that is
every scene from this point on is so
integral to story lines set up in season
one
and characters that are so integral to
this
story right so we see this starts with
june and luke
struggling to get intimate in the
kitchen but this is setting up payoff
for june and luke later on but it
brilliantly then cuts to them
in the bedroom and they can't get
intimate right which we just saw in the
kitchen but june
is thinking about serena and this is
part of her mindset right she's got
her brain on these things that are very
important to her but before we get
into what this is all setting up and
leading to the big moment with serena in
june
let's go to the first scene we see of
the waterfords and serena here but
serena
is praying in this chapel she's like
whatever i can do to repent and redeem
myself in your eyes i will do it
and this is her character classically
using religious mercy to justify
her bad behavior but what you're seeing
and like i was just talking about is
that serena
can see some wicked things she's done
she's not totally
ignorant to what she does it's that she
chooses to
ignore it when it's necessary for what
she needs and
what this episode's doing so well with
her story is that she knows that
she's starting to try to change again a
little bit right and
not have her son pay for her sins like
she says but
when there's a threat to her son and
what she wants at the end of the day in
her dream life
she'll do anything then and screw anyone
else that gets in her way no matter
what that is serena at the end of the
day and that's what makes her so cruel
and i think she's still the most
fascinating complex character that's
ever been on this show and i still would
love to know more about why she is the
way she is
they kind of did that story a bit with
her and her mom which wasn't that great
i kind of want to know more about those
flashbacks when it's like
gilead starting and her being someone
who's really behind all this
and why she was so strong about her
beliefs and what it
really is her motivation of the day i
really would like to learn more about
this character it's just fascinating
and what's messed up about mark here is
when he comes in and now they're talking
about june
being here he is basically looking out
for serena still and he's
letting her know like you know you can
now get the upper hand on fred because
this is
obviously bad news for you that june's
here but it's horrible news for fred
right
and he knows that this is just part of
his plan that at the end of the day
mark wants to have fred kind of just
take the fall here
and get this big wig from gilead out
it's going to make him look good at his
job but also
for some reason whether he's got the
hots for her or not i'd interview the
actor mark and he believes that mark
does have a thing
for serena so that's part of it too he's
under her spell right
and it's messed up even more because he
already debriefed
june heard all this bad stuff about
serena from her and still goes to help
serena out here
but you see when she goes to meet fred
fred makes a point how
we need to drop our fight i'll drop my
testimony against you
because the real threat is june and she
can put us both away for maximum
sentence
but he knows serena and what will get
her and he says i'll pull my testimony
because have a good life for our son
it's all about
the kid for serena here and he's like
why wouldn't you do this so it's always
her driving force and he knows that
so let's go to this incredible scene
where june goes to see serena and what's
crazy we get this split dioperator shot
that you would see a lot of horror films
of serena when june's walking in the
background
and remember her motivation in this
scene serena is just to make
peace with june so that june doesn't
testify against her
and that it won't threat this life she
can have with her child
okay and her first plan here was to just
somehow get jun not angry right and
forgive her
and make amends and her backup which
you'll eventually see her go to because
it doesn't work
is then to actually do what fred wants
and that they would team up
and have to join together to go against
june again it's all from her selfish
needs
and there's some amazing writing here
where serena's like i prayed for this
chance and i humbly thank the lord for
this visit
and jun's like you would never give me
credit for anything
and then she says you don't deserve to
make amends for anything only thing you
deserve is a life full of suffering and
shame
and i love while she's saying these
lines it's showing that famous two shot
where serene is always hovering
over june and now it's the tables have
turned right this is the first time
we're seeing june talking to serena off
of gilead turf
serena has no power over her serena now
even
bends the need to her and there's again
more great writing where jun's like
listing off all the things the awful
thing serena's done that she has that
way
even on the audience to make you forget
about right and she says there is no one
less
worthy of redemption than you are and
sorry serena stands because there's some
out there
that always want to give her a second
chance it's over for okay
so first off props to yvonne strawski
the delivery of her line when she says
i'm sorry to june is masterful
because she's saying it but she doesn't
really mean it but it's what she needs
to do
it's just she shows it so perfectly and
when elizabeth moss
just lays into serena here holy
oh my god oh my god
i got such chills down my spine and
here's the thing elizabeth moss someone
who's won a lot of awards
and then what ends up happening is that
people are like i'll give someone else a
chance you know i'm not a believer in
that
it's like with sports right if michael
jordan keeps winning if tom brady keeps
winning
you know someone beat them then you know
don't just give out an award because
they've won too much
you just keep going you want to be the
greatest right and elizabeth moss is a
legend
this i'm sorry seals the deal for me i
don't know how you can top this as
another emmy win just for this scene
alone
and why it's so powerful is a couple
things because
think about how long we have waited for
this moment this is payoff
for four seasons of waiting now june to
say her piece to serena
and that's what i love about television
compared to movies is that you get these
cathartic moments that you've waited so
long for and it really
really hits but of course it's the
acting here that's just incredible by
both of them
but what elizabeth moss is able to do
here
is to tap into for me was watching this
i've seen people at this state i've been
at this state that she's
in and i think everyone can agree with
that and you can recognize it
you can recognize her being able to turn
that on which was just
so powerful and why this scene works for
writing
everything directing cinematography is
because
it's not just about this payoff for this
long arc with
june versus serena it's also going to
the hope and theme of our hero why
june is our hero and the point of this
show is that this is a
victim speaking up to her abuser and
people that unfortunately
don't get the opportunity to do this in
life you can feel it here there's a
cathartic
feeling and it's why we do this right
it's why we watch art it's why
film and tv can do things no other art
can do and
that's it right there that's why this is
the best scene of the handmaid cell to
me ever made
because it's literally that feeling
that's been built up to get this moment
and to see serena crying there and again
people connect of
being victims and having that moment to
stick up to your
abuser and why this is also great
is because in the next scene that moment
when she goes to
have an intimate moment with luke she's
able to do it and the reason she's so
like wanting to do it for herself is
because that who's that is who june is
she wants to claim her life back
and it's perfect to fit her character
like i said where she's not gonna be a
victim anymore she's gonna claim her
life back
she's gonna stick up to these evil
people and she's gonna
try her best to be herself again
so again the writing here fantastic
shout out again to jalen chan here
amazing writing when she's
writing june's final debrief here to
mark about serena and jun's like she's
pathological sociopath abusive toxic
a monster and mark says what do you
think drives her
she says hatred rage and underneath all
of that there is nothing misery so this
is really
nailing serena at the end of the day and
we all have met people like this
and it's like you're closest to as like
evil a person can get right because a
lot of people are gray everyone's really
great
the other day but then there is some
evil there are evil people
and serena is that and it's because
she's
conscious of what she's doing that's bad
and knows she's doing it
for her selfish needs and you see like i
said it's cutting brilliantly with this
or it's like serena couldn't win june
over so now she goes to her next play
which is like i need you fred
and it's perfectly just showing you
visually while jun's explaining with her
narration
and she would do anything not to feel
that way do anything to get what she
wants
lie do you hurt you rape you so if you
feel yourself getting sucked
in by her run run for your life she's
saying this to somebody who is getting
sucked in by her currently which is mark
so that works so well too
and it's a beautiful blend here with
showing serena right and
june didn't fall for her trap stuck up
to her and it's showing june like i said
claiming her life back with luke and
playing with nicole outside
and adam taylor's masterful score here
just seals the deal this is incredible
work of art
i was blown away by this and it's a
message of hope for people who are
victims
of abuse and that you can live another
day
and be strong and do what you really
want to do and be free again
and i thought this really showed that
and there's no fix you covers by
coldplay here which is just great
because i'm still having nightmares
about that and look everything directing
writing cinematography
acting i mean it's my favorite episode
of the show this isn't recency bias this
is
something you hoped for a great show
like this with such a great season one
really good season two and three this
season's been really good
and but you hope right that when the
payoffs do come in a show like this that
they land
this lands you couldn't have done it any
better this scene with her and serena
you just
couldn't have so everything here for me
is a 10.
everything serves something here in this
episode you get little payoffs here
from things set up in this episode and
bigger payoffs from things set up
throughout the show as a whole it's my
new favorite episode yet
uh it's a 10 clearly and thank you to
richard shepard
who directed this yalin chang who wrote
it elizabeth moss yvonne scherzki
really hard last name to say but i said
it they all killed it here
amazing adam taylor coming through the
score as usual just everybody bruce moe
the creator
i'm really kissing up here because i'm
just so happy there's still
good content like this in shows like
this and i'm still blown away that if
you go
to critics who rated this and they saw
this episode because there was eight
episodes released they gave the season a
lot of low scores
i don't know what they were watching i
don't know what they're thinking
people are sheep sometimes and they just
hear like oh this is just torture porn
and then everyone takes that
angle now like no one's thinking for
themselves and going case by case
episode by episode i try to do that
and uh yeah i think you're crazy if you
don't think this is incredible but i
think it's amazing especially because
they film this during a pandemic as well
and they're able to still pull this off
so
it's a 10 for me let me know what you
thought of it down below i love to hear
your thoughts i read every comment i try
to respond as many as i can
please check out now my channel
memberships there are three tiers
the first tier is only two bucks second
tier is only three bucks and the last
tier is five bucks but that will give
you access to exclusive live streams i'm
going to be doing q and a's
and any tier you get some cool badges
and it really helps as a donation for me
so i can do more videos for you guys and
do this full time one day it would be a
dream for me so any support
i really really appreciate and please
follow me at steve harley show on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time when you try
your best but you don't succeed
when you get what you are but know what
you need